welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i speak with dr safidine
amos
an economist and the author of the
bitcoin standard the decentralized
alternative to central banking
which has been published in 20 languages
now last week i released more of an
intro episode to bitcoin and i decided
to learn
a little bit more about it safety and
delves deeper into the economics behind
bitcoin specifically
i would recommend listening to the
episode with bitstein if you need more
of an
intro episode first safety really knows
economics something i know nothing about
although now i know slightly less than
nothing and hopefully you will too
dr amos is an independent scholar who
publishes his research
and teaches a university-level
curriculum in economics in the austrian
school tradition
on his website safeadeen.com he speaks
at conferences all over the world about
economics and frequently discusses
specifically
the economics behind bitcoin safeidine
is also a carnivore
we spoke a little bit about why the
bitcoin community seems to be into the
carnivore diet
something i think makes sense given how
simple it is and how great it makes you
feel
but it's also kind of funny bitcoin
carnivores
a word from the sponsor of this episode
i've been using true local
for a couple years and they are my go-to
source for meat at home in canada
what they do is they partner with local
farmers and butchers in your area
to source some of the best meat things
like 100 grass-fed and grass-finished
beef
pasture-raised or rwa chicken means
raised without antibiotics
lamb buffalo and over 100 different cuts
of meat that you can't find at your
grocery store generally
you build your own personalized box that
will give you enough meat for the month
with only the products you want and it
shows up at your door
another thing i've been loving with it
is all the products come individually
portioned and vacuum sealed
if you've been thinking about giving
true local a shot i'd say
it's worth it use the code mp to get two
free revise with your order
this is where i get all of my meat for
us canadians
i hope you enjoy this episode please
remember to subscribe and leave a review
if you
like the episode and would like to hear
more
[Music]
welcome safe thanks for coming on to my
podcast thank you for having me
i thought we should get started just by
you giving my audience a bit of a
background about who you are and what
you do
at this point i'm an independent uh
author
and uh researcher and teacher
online i used to be in academia i was a
university professor at the lebanese
american university
um in beirut lebanon but
i about a few months ago i quit that job
and now i'm
full-time focused on reading
writing and researching and teaching on
bitcoin so i run my own website
um my own website saferdean.com on which
i teach courses
on austrian school economics and bitcoin
and um i write about i write my research
on
bitcoin mainly in the economics of
bitcoin and uh
i'm working on another couple of books
as well
oh i am written the bitcoin standard i
guess i should have mentioned that yeah
yeah that's how that's how i learned
about you um
this is kind of a selfish podcast
because i want to learn a lot more about
bitcoin and i find it difficult to know
where to start i've used it a bit for
purchases online so i have figured it
out but it took me a while to figure out
how to buy it
what apps to use how to transfer it so i
thought
well so i want to get started by
asking you some of the basics on how to
use bitcoin what the purpose is
if you should invest just stuff like
that so i think we'll do that and then
get a bit into
um how you are how you
act as a successful person uh what your
life kind of looks like because i've
been asking a lot of people who come on
my podcast that just to see if there are
any patterns
so to get started
um what's the just a really brief
background of what bitcoin is like when
did it start who invented it
what is it bitcoin is basically
uh without trying without getting too
technical
i'll just focus on functional
perspective you know
i'm not gonna try and explain to you how
a car works i'm just going to tell you
what you can do with the car basically
yeah yeah
bitcoin is just a new form of money um
which is which can be used for all the
things that your money
other forms of money can be used for
except that this one is
not produced by a government and it's
also not a precious metal
um it's a new form a new animal a new
species
that we've discovered which is
completely digital
and yet its supply is verifiably scarce
so it's been operating for uh 11 years
now
and during those 11 years we've seen it
we know exactly how many bitcoin there
are and at any point in time
it's possible for anybody to verify how
many bitcoins
there are so even though it's digital
and we
we intuitively understand that digital
things cannot be scarce because you can
just copy things
um endlessly in the cost of copying
digital things is
uh very very low with the
bitcoin we see the first example of
digital's carson we see something that's
actually scarce
in the digital realm there's only going
to be 21 million bitcoins
and it's never going to be more and you
know
it's quite complicated how this gets
accomplished you can read about it more
in my book
but ultimately this is the end result
and this is i think the significant
invention which is that we
for the first time have a money that is
um fixed in its
supply and the uh
the amazing thing about it also is that
it is completely apolitical
it's completely technological solution
to the problem of money
it doesn't require government's
permission to work it doesn't require
government
supervision regulation authority which
to an extent
other kinds of money require
almost inherently so government money
has to be controlled by government
because that's the point and even
precious metals
you know their clearance requires
central banks that are heavily
centralized that can be
easily captured and taken over by
governments
and so the ability to um
control the clearance of precious metals
is what makes them um what makes it
quite likely and possible throughout
history for governments to go off the
gold standard
so bitcoin is a new form of money that
is much more decentralized
so it doesn't have more as much
centralization as gold would have which
therefore makes it
less likely to be centralized and
captured and attacked
um by governments less likely for
governments to be able to
build uh inflationary monies on top of
it
whether that works or not is something
to remain seen over time but this is the
this is the monster that we have
uncovered with this thing
okay so that all makes sense um so in
theory that sounds like it would be
less volatile so why do we see such
like why is bitcoin so volatile if
that's how it works
um i don't i don't think it i don't
necessarily think it would in theory be
more volatile
the the supply is fixed but the demand
is um
varying because people are discovering
bitcoin all over the world every day
and um you know it's it's it's a new
thing it's very hard to understand
it's very hard to get a grip of how this
thing works like you need to
develop some at least intuitive
understanding of several fields of
expertise
um in order to be able to just grasp how
bitcoin works
you need to get the idea of what
cryptography is you want to understand
how
cryptography works and how bitcoin
employs that you need to think about say
how
distributed networks work you need to
think about the economics of it the
computer science the coding
a lot of things that are not necessarily
um sharing the same uh
pool of expertise are required to
understand how bitcoin operates so
there's a lot of misinformation out
there and there's a lot of people that
don't really get
what is going on and so over time you
know um
people are just discovering this the
market is discovering it and we're
witnessing the discovery process happen
day to day as people buy more uh bitcoin
and sell bitcoin
and you know speculate on what's going
to happen to its value
um i i think the volatility is
likely to be a feature for a while but i
think eventually
um the the the reason it's there is that
at this point bitcoin's
entire market capitalization is pretty
small whereas uh
you know if you compare it to other
money so the total value of all bitcoins
that are out there
something like 200 billion dollars which
is
about 0.1.2 of uh
the total global money supply depends on
how you count it
so there's still a little drop in the
ocean uh well
maybe a drop in a bucket let's say um
but
over time if that so being at such a
small
size means it's quite likely that if one
individual
yeah who's got a lot of money is going
to be buying or selling that it's going
to be
very volatile but if the market grows
and the size of the liquidity pool
of bitcoin holders grows much more
then individual large transactions will
still
be um insignificant toward
attaining the final um toward affecting
the final price
significantly every day so i think as
bitcoin grows you'd expect to see its
volatility decline
um but it's still a long way away okay
um and what kind of growth is bitcoin
seeing now
is it still what it was when it you know
shot up when it was in the news
and like is it still or is it
exponential what kind of growth are we
seeing
yeah it's uh i mean it depends on what
time frame you look at but if you look
at the first 10 years of trading bitcoin
was up
around 800 million percent
over the 10 years that's generally the
uh
yeah i mean a lot of that came at the
beginning but still
even if you look at the past five years
for instance uh
five years ago it was say january 2015 i
would imagine bitcoin then was around
200 bucks or something like that 300
bucks so now it's around 9
000. so it's gone up about 40
fold in the space of the five years so
it's an enormous
uh growth in the long run but a lot of
volatility in the short run
so that's something to keep in mind that
it's not something
you should go into with a lot of
uh you know with an expectation for a
short-term
return because in the short term if
you're dependent on it
uh if you're counting on a short-term
return you could get burned pretty bad
because there's
a lot of short-term volatility but and
if you keep a long-term perspective on
it then
it seems to me and that's the point in
my book that i discussed in my book in
the bitcoin standard that
the only way to understand why bitcoin
does this the only reason
that the only way that we can understand
why bitcoin rises so much is because
it's a new way of doing money it's a new
technology for money and it functions
where it functions the way in which the
supply is completely irresponsive to the
map
so no matter how much the demand for
bitcoin rises we can't make more
bitcoins
whereas with all other things in the
world if the demand rises we can always
find
more but bitcoin is not like that
okay that makes sense so that sounds
complicated
um so how is somebody like money is easy
for people to understand and to use
um and it took me like i feel like i'm
fairly smart and it took me a while to
figure out how to use bitcoin and how to
send it
um and the apps are pretty good but it's
still complicated so
how how are people expected to learn how
to do this like
i mean that's one of the things that's
stopping it right
yeah well i so that one way of looking
at it
there's the perspective of thinking of
it as like it's an as if it's like an
app
on your phone and we need to get to
grow toward the level of mass adoption
and um we're waiting for people to like
this app
enough for it to take off
but i think that's an inappropriate
analogy for understanding bitcoin
that's how i understand it so far so far
maybe this podcast will change that
yeah i mean you know people have
disagreed before on
many things it happens but i think a
better way of thinking of it
is that um this is not just a matter of
adoption it's not about somebody
deciding all right
i'm going to switch from mac to android
or uh from one platform to the other
from one
um social network to the other it's it's
it's quite different because this is a
liquidity decision and
everybody's liquidity um in
in in terms of their cash balance
everybody's cash balance is held in the
currencies
in which they transact most of their
transactions
in which they have their existing
contracts so you already have
contracts with say people um that work
for you or people you work for
and things that you buy all of your
expenditures are denominated in your
local currency that's the case for
pretty much everybody in the world so
it's not you know no matter how nice you
make
the uh apps that's one thing
and your liquidity decision is is is a
separate question so you moving
even if i made you the best app involved
for bitcoin and bitcoin was
let's say the iphone of money and every
other money
out there was like uh you know the 1970s
fax machines
or did they even have i thought you were
going to throw a phone company
down there yeah but i mean you know if
if you have even if it was this advanced
it's still a very complicated decision
for you to make
to make that switch because all of your
uh liquidity all of your cash balance
has to be
in the currencies in which you're
getting your
income and making your expenditures so
effectively what's going to happen is um
it's going to be a slow process for
people to build
up liquid cash balances in bitcoin and
that's what we're seeing happen
if you think about it this way as a
liquid cash balance is an economic
phenomenon which is how i
see it and how i understand it it has
been growing
enormously fast i mean astonishingly
fast you know the bitcoins market cap
has gone from zero to 200 billion
in about uh 10 years
which is astonishing you know the total
size of the bitcoin
uh currency out there is
roughly or a little larger than the size
of the currency of
your of some medium-sized middle-income
country or
large small country so you know i think
at this point it's like roughly
somewhere around the size of
egypt's uh currency so you know egypt's
been around for thousands of years
and their currency um has been matched
the size of the currency the market
value of the currency the cash balances
held in the egyptian pound
are equal to about the cash balances
held in
a digital currency that's been built
over the past 10 years
so wow that's that's the way that i like
to think about it and
um for me i think the issue of the user
interface
and the app and the use of the app that
you're going to be
employing that's um
honestly that's that for me is almost
something that is completely orthogonal
has a question to the adoption of
bitcoin because at the end of the day
you could ultimately have um bitcoin
run with any kind
of payment technology that you can have
on any other form of money
i mean at the end of the day if you're
going to be paying for
your day-to-day transactions with your
phone or with your credit card
you know it's say you're there's a
separate a completely separate
decision of the currency versus the
um user interface so you could have any
kind of user interface like paypal and
venmo
and american express or uh checkbooks or
wire transfers you can have all of these
done with dollars or
canadian dollars or uh any currency
around the world or
gold or bitcoin and so the the
the actual interface and the user
experience is going to
evolve significantly over time um and i
think
more and more of the day-to-day use by
individuals is going to be
um mediated through these kinds of
technologies that make it very
intuitive you know we can even have
physical bitcoin things like open dime
which is uh
very easy to verify you can put any sum
of bitcoin on it
and it's just like a usb drive it's very
easy to move around
so there will be more and more of these
intuitive interfaces and solutions
i think over time yeah okay i've been
using brd
which has been useful for me but um that
okay that kind of segues into
the main question i got asked i asked on
instagram if anyone had questions
regarding bitcoin that they they wanted
me to ask and the main question was how
do i start
like do you have websites you recommend
people go to
or apps to use in order to really get
started for someone who doesn't know
anything about bitcoin
where to buy it i mean there is an
enormous amount of good resources online
i think um where to buy it is is
is a question that is going to require
you to do your own research i don't like
to answer that question myself because
um you know i first of all depends on
where you are and depends on
um you know what platform works best for
you but there's a
very large amount of service providers
out there that you could use uh
shouldn't take much um there's a lot of
websites i should have
um maybe prepare this answer the
question i have to say my own work i
study the
economics of bitcoin i don't i don't
have any particular product
uh any particular work i've done myself
on um
on how to use it and so on but i would
recommend
um i think there's a website that helped
me many years ago and it's still out
there it's called start using
bitcoin.com
that seems seems like a good place to
start
yeah um
i think there's that and if i think of
any other thing else
there's also um a web page by jameson
lop
it's lop.net bitcoin
dash information and that contains a lot
of information on
um that it contains all kinds of
different information
from all different aspects that you
might want to look at
related to bitcoin okay cool um
so then for the average person let's say
who has a little bit of money in savings
is there
is there an amount you think people
should invest in or is this not
something
you suggesting i mean you said if you're
looking for short-term gains this is not
how to do it
but is there like a percentage of money
if you have some sitting that you're
looking to invest that you would
recommend investing into bitcoin
i i'm not an investment advisor and i'm
really hesitant to answer questions like
that because
it's not my job and you know um
you don't get remembered for uh
providing a good answer you only
providing a bad answer and then you know
you have people
angry at you so i really um
you know i i i i don't know uh
and the honest answer is that i don't
know what the correct percentage for you
is it depends on your own
portfolio what you want your own risk
version what other kinds of investments
you're undertaking
so there are really no easy answers on
it but i would recommend
the idea of what bitcoin is called
dollar
cost averaging i think this is a good
idea in which
you instead of thinking about buying
bitcoin in terms of lump sums
and thinking about buying it based on
trying to time the market
so thinking to yourself that you know i
think uh now the price is high i'm gonna
wait until the next couple of months
when it drops i'll buy
a lot of people do that and then the
price shoots up and then you end up
buying
a quarter as much as you could have
bought initially
and that uh that
desire to try and time the market in the
short run
can be extremely stressful and almost
always
um counterproductive you're not going to
be the market the market is extremely
unpredictable
in bitcoin because um you know in the
short run it's massively volatile
and there are countless
stories and dead bodies of people who
have tried to time the market and end up
getting wrecked
so the best way i think to approach it
if you're getting in it
is to use this concept of dollar cost
averaging where you decide on
an amount that you're going to be
purchasing per week or per day
per month and just so some services can
even automate this for you
so they'll they'll take a debit from
your bank account say once a month or
once a week or once a day
and buy at whatever the price is on that
day
and so this way you know you'll know
that whatever
variation and oscillation is happening
during the month
you're being you're ensuring that you
don't you're not buying at the worst
time possible you know there's a spike
you buy and then it crashes
you're getting a nice average of it and
in the long run um
this seems to pretty much beat pretty
much anything like uh
then there's a website i think it's
called dca bitcoin
um which shows you a calculation
of how much you would have um
how much you know if you had yeah it's
dca btc
it'll show you if you put in say ten
dollars weekly
forever for the last three years how
much would it be worth today so
ah yeah so you would have invested
for instance that's the um one on the
page right now if you've done
ten dollars weekly for the past three
years you'd have had uh you'd have
invested one thousand five hundred and
seventy dollars but it
would be worth two thousand six hundred
and twenty six
so in the long run um you know
because bitcoin has this upside trend
even the times when bitcoin is rising
and falling you end up doing
okay overall because you end up buying
at the times when it's very low as well
as the time when it's high so
you're getting the reliable long-term
appreciation uh
without having to stress about it okay
that sounds like a very good way to
start yeah and also i think another
another important aspect of it is
you know it allows you to um decide on
how much you want to go in
um depending on how much
you're willing to risk into it then i
generally recommend you know the more
confident you are the more you read
about it the more you understand that
the better you'll you know
the more you should be putting into it
if you're not very confident
in it you could end up losing your keys
and this is very important
you need to understand what you're doing
because you could end up losing some of
your money
or all of it in that case um and
but with this case you know you can go
in a small
enough sum to feel comfortable so that
even
if there is a massive crash at some
point the way the price
drops or even if you know because you're
new and you make a massive mistake where
you
end up losing some coins or whatever or
whatever
you're still dipping your toes in at
small amounts and you're not going to
get burned
uh losing serious money it's not going
to be
um even if there is a crash say you know
you you were putting in
a small sum every week it wasn't a
life-changing
sum and so it's not going to be massive
in its negative impact on you okay that
makes sense
um can you delve into that a bit about
some of the mistakes you can make
because
if there's anyone listening who doesn't
know anything about bitcoin i don't know
if people are aware that you can
just lose things and then lose all your
money
yeah basically you know you think about
a bitcoin transaction as
um in a sense bitcoin has been
[Music]
mis-evangelized
at some point in which people presented
it as if it was just
the iphone of uh money where everything
else is just uh
abacuses and old
metal coins and uh you know the idea was
that this was going to be
extremely fast and efficient and free
you know free costless instant
transactions around the world is is what
some of the people were saying around
uh 2012 2013 about bitcoin and that's
just not accurate a bitcoin transaction
is not uh something it's not like the
iphone version of your credit card
transaction a bitcoin transaction is the
um
it's the you can think about it as the
concord
um the concord airliner version of
a transatlantic trip it's the most
advanced
way of sending um you know a passenger
uh a bunch of passengers across the
atlantic we've done that with
uh little boats we've done that with
bigger boats and then we started doing
that with airplanes
and the most advanced best way of doing
it was the concord which did it in three
hours
um bitcoin is this in a sense that
you can think there's about half a
million or three hundred thousand daily
bitcoin
transactions um that take place on chain
and these are movements of value that
could
send say 10 billion dollars from the us
to china
and when you think about it this way
this is what you need to understand when
you're handling one of these
transactions it's
you you're almost in a sense
engaging in something that's
industrial and technical and not very uh
not very simple you know you're
it because because the correct
comparison is to compare it to
central bank supplement of payment
because what's what's unique about a
bitcoin transaction
is that it is a final separate
transaction in other words when you
pay for your lunch with a credit card
that's not similar to when your central
bank is settling with uh
china's central bank um when you pay
with a credit card you know it's
marked on your statement and it goes to
the merchant but they
get paid after uh several days or weeks
or months
and for the transaction to finally clear
completely and so that there can be no
more
dispute and no more return on the
transaction it takes a significant
amount of time
central banks you know they when
um they carry out final settlement
transactions between one another or
large financial institutions will carry
out large financial
settlements between one another bitcoin
is like that because a bitcoin
transaction
once it takes place it's irreversible
there's no
do-over there's no call customer service
support and ask for it to be
returned you've uploaded a concord
and you've sent it across the atlantic
there's no do-over button
um it's it's not like uh your apple pay
it's not like your credit card you can't
just call customer support service and
tell them
i didn't make this transaction and then
they would say contact the merchant and
cancel the transaction before the
merchant ships the good
and so there is a do-over button if you
lose your credit card bitcoin is not
like that if you lose your private keys
they're gone nobody will find it so this
is really the most important thing
just um being able to own bitcoin means
that you own
you have to own your own private keys um
and i recommend reading and
understanding what private keys are
and thinking very carefully about how
you
are able to keep your private keys safe
and there's no correct
answer to what is the best way of doing
this because
that depends on your own competence your
own
security situation what you feel
comfortable handling and
the kind of risk you're willing to take
okay um and then just to get i'm just
going to delve into that a little bit
because i think people will be
interested
but um the main way people use
is it physical that people keep physical
keys
is that the most popular way do you
think the hardware wallet
yeah yeah i mean what you do
with the hardware wallet effectively is
that you
uh a hardware wallet is a way of having
the
private keys on a device that is
independent which makes the security
of the coins simpler rather than having
it on your computer because your
computer
has all kinds of security holes in it
from
all kinds of problems so if you have the
hardware separate then you know securing
the hardware
becomes a simpler issue so a lot of
people like
using hardware wallets um cold card
is a good one and um trezor is another
popular one
oh yeah so these are worth looking into
they simplify the security
uh question because once it becomes and
they also make the issue more intuitive
like
once you see that hardware wallet it's
um you know
it's it's like when you give a cell
phone to an old person for the first
time
it's intuitive you click those numbers
and uh or you know you you
you click on the touch screen and things
happen and then they'll figure out their
way around it
when you see it on on a hardware wallet
it can be a little bit like that
but you see the coins are innocent
they're not there
the password is what's there but this is
the device that
can use the um not the password the
private keys this is the device that can
use the private keys to
um send and to send coins
yeah and the downside of that and i feel
like i've read about this in buzzfeed or
something the downside of that is if you
lose it
you can lose your money in there like
you said there's no customer service
well not quite because with the hardware
wallet you kind of do have some level of
security in which
um you can have a password on the
hardware wallet that makes it harder for
somebody to crack it
and you can have a backup with the seeds
awards that you can keep somewhere and
then um
so you know the wallet is would be
something that you would use
to make transactions but the seed would
be something held in somewhere
safe and then if you can recover it from
the sea
but then of course that introduces
another level of problems which is how
you make sure that nobody can see the
sea so
yeah it's um i mean i i have to say this
is very early days
in bitcoin the way that think about it
and this is why these things are
um a little bit more uh
raw for the user experience i tend to
think however as i was saying
um for me as i discussed in my book i
think the reason bitcoin
is compelling is not the user interface
and not the ease of use and it's um and
one one analogy i like to make all the
time is the bitcoin is not going to be
adopted like the iphone because it's
easy and fun to use
it's going to be adopted like gunpowder
it's bitcoin's financial dynamic
basically
and so nobody was complaining about the
ease of use
of dynamite um if you didn't like to use
dynamite if you didn't like to use
gunpowder
someone else was going to use it against
you so better
uh suck it up and learn how to use
gunpowder i like that
yeah i think this is really the point
that um people
are used to thinking of bitcoin from the
perspective of
you know sell me on bitcoin it's the new
facebook where's the new twitter well i
don't like the new twitter
or i don't like this app or i don't like
this iphone you don't like this thing
about
a bitcoin and my reactions generally
were good you know
more bitcoin for other people
um it's in a sense you know
what has happened with money
historically is that the hardest money
ends up
getting adopted people end up using the
hardest thing as money
and the thing that is the hardest to
make ends up holding on to its value and
other things
continue to lose their values so uh you
know
uh that's why yeah societies that used
to run and i've discussed this
extensively in my book societies that
had say
seashells or limestones as money that
stuff worked as
a money for as long as it was the
hardest thing
to produce on these islands but then
once modern civilization started coming
in
and people could dig for more seashells
increasingly in
increasing numbers and also people could
use other forms of money like gold
and other currencies in silver
then it doesn't matter what seashell
users
felt about the gold user experience you
know
the seashells became worthless and the
limestones became worthless and
the money became gold because all the
other money was
too easy and its value kept on declining
and the people who held it dumped it
and so the people who wanted to continue
to remain
fixated you know if there were some
seashell fanatics who said
no no no i like the sound of seashells
as money and i'm never going to switch
over to gold
they just ended up with bucket loads of
seashells
in their homes and nobody willing to
take them
from them so money ended up being gold
if they needed to
eat if they needed to actually buy
anything they still needed
to go and get actual gold no matter how
many seashells they have so
this is kind of the key point in the
earlier chapters of my book which is
that
the hardness of money ends up um being
probably the most important thing about
it this is why if we look at national
currencies
we see that national currencies that
have a relatively low supply growth rate
like say the us dollar
or um the euro these currencies tend to
hold on to their value relatively well
whereas national currencies that have
very fast growth rates
like zimbabwe and venezuela and all of
these continue to lose
their value much faster
and um the user experience of
handling the different kind of notes or
the payment portals
that different central banks employ are
largely inconsequential details
compared to the hardness of the supply
that's why i think
bitcoin is so interesting because its
supply is going to become the hardest
or is right now around the same supply
growth rate as
gold but over the next couple years is
going to drop even below that of gold
okay um i got interested i think more in
bitcoin other than
you know i'm in the carnivore sphere and
for some reason
that has a lot of people who are into
bitcoin we'll get into that later
but i got interested because the
downstairs corner store suddenly had a
bitcoin machine
i was like what that that's weird and
then i started going on websites and
there were a few websites that were also
accepting bitcoin and then i went on a
couple of websites and they only
accepted bitcoin
and i was like whoa okay so this must be
growing and that's when i started
figuring out how to learn to use it
because i wanted to buy some things
online that i
couldn't use a visa for which was really
interesting so this is all
this is all good to know um what are
your what are your thoughts on
alternative coins
other than bitcoin is there anything to
that yeah they're all scams
basically okay that's amazing
kind of made my name as just you know
the
i i was one of the earliest uh boys
who cried the emperor has no clothes
on this issue from quite early on just
saying look
bitcoin's all we get either bitcoin
works
in this entire experiment either bitcoin
works
and um nothing else works or nothing
works
those are our only two options um and
you know that i've written about it in
my book and i've discussed this
extensively on my twitter and in many
different forums and um
ultimately um i'll just summarize the
main point in my view
is that um the only thing that makes
bitcoin valuable is the fact that the
supply
is
scarce and nobody can change the supply
the fact that the supply is verifiable
because
if there was an easy way to just make
more bitcoin tomorrow
somebody could print more bitcoin and
that would describe the entire value
proposition there's no physical scarcity
barrier that prevents somebody from
making 10 quadrillion bitcoins tomorrow
um
the only barrier is the fact that um
well it's not the only battery it's a
very significant barrier is the fact
that
the bitcoin code is effectively
unchangeable
because in order for somebody to change
it you need to get full consensus
and there's nobody who's in control of
bitcoin who can achieve that consensus
and force everybody to change
whereas all the and that's because of
the unique way in which bitcoin grew
bitcoin was introduced by somebody who
was anonymous and they disappeared and
it continued to grow
without the central figurehead which is
incredible because it was a technology
that was being used by all kinds of
people none of whom could control it
after the uh initial guide left the
initial
founder left and the fact that they
haven't been around that they haven't
um contributed anything towards
the running of the coin or at least um
even you know
as far as we know maybe they use another
identity for it but
the fact that the founder is gone and
the fact that the
coin is outside and the fact that we've
seen over the past 10 12 years
so many people try to change so many
things about bitcoin and fail
repeatedly is the only reason that i
think bitcoin has any kind of
scarcity and therefore any kind of value
now none of the other coins really has
that
um none of the other coins has this
idea that it is a technology that nobody
controls there is somebody who basically
controls each one of the other points
okay those coins you know they
they were started after bitcoin had
already had
an advantage so the only way that you
could start these points was that you
needed a group of people working on them
as a team
and that team had to foster this thing
mine and to grow it support it code it
debug it um and do all of the things
that was
needed for this little project to grow
so there's no way that that team could
then
claim not to be in charge and you see
through the years the development of
these currencies
is pretty straightforward and
um you know it's it's it's like a
startup there all these other digital
currencies are like a startup which for
me is
is is the wrong business model if you're
starting the currency
you're just not going to get anywhere if
you're doing it as a currency because
um i mean ultimately government will
shut you down but even if they didn't
it's quite likely that um you know
it's a bunch of humans in charge of a
currency and so it's the same thing as
money yeah um okay so what what do you
think about the problem
what do you think about the strife
that's gonna happen with the government
uh considering you can't track it so
people are gonna be
you know taxed there's gonna be tax
evasion and everything is that going to
be
do you see that as a problem in the
future
i mean i i think actually bitcoin is
it's it's a misconception that bitcoin
is not trackable bitcoin is quite well
trackable
um it's um
you know the way that the network works
is that each time you spend a coin
the transaction is announced uh is
announced to everybody else in the
network
and so it's not very easy to hide your
tracks
and i keep telling people you know if
you think that you are
capable of doing uh bitcoin anonymously
you probably don't know what you're
talking about very few people are really
capable of doing this well enough and i
think um i i
i don't think it's going to continue to
be
i think with time it's going to get less
and less anonymous and
it's not going to be um
i think it's it's going to be a very bad
idea for people who want to use it
um for doing uh criminal things
and in fact if we look at bitcoin
uh holders now you know the majority of
the demand
exists with people who
are pretty well um
very easy to identify because they
bought bitcoin from exchanges that are
connected
to the government uh that use uh
kyc and aml so you know
about a quarter of all bitcoins at least
is held by bitcoin exchanges
and so it's held for you under their
name uh i mean it's
they hold it for you under your name so
they know who you are
so i i think the criminal aspect of
uh the use of bitcoin for doing things
that are criminal or things that are
against the law is massively overstated
the majority of the people are using
bitcoin because they use it for what
bitcoiners call
the revolutionary number go up
technology
it's because they're holding on to it so
that they can sell it tomorrow for a
higher price
and you know this offends a lot of
people
in particular in silicon valley because
you know
life is all about buzzwords and um
giving yourself lofty uh
ideals to pretend to be appealing to and
so
for them crypto is about all of these um
you know
we need to work on crypto and we need
all these currencies that will do all
kinds of
um amazing wonderful things for
inclusion and all
of these you know the regular buzzwords
of every
um everything in the world
but really bitcoin does one thing and
all this
blockchain technology stuff is good for
one thing and that is
number go up everybody can buy it and
there's no way for the
no way for anybody to make more of it
and burst the bubble effect
it's a bubble that continues to burst
upwards it bursts when it bursts and
bursts but
every time it bursts to a level that is
higher than where it was before
so um it
it's it's it's going to be more and more
of this kind of investors
and holders of bitcoin i think over time
rather than
the uh criminal uh use of ironman
so hopefully that brought everyone
listening
back down to earth who wants to use
bitcoin because it's untrackable
for criminal activities yeah if you want
to use if you have criminal needs you
know stick to the us dollar
the national currency of criminals of
choice
okay okay well that was that was very
informative and i'm gonna go check out
those websites you mentioned i'll also
link them
um to the show notes here and below um
in that okay so let's delve into more of
the carnivore sphere because i know that
you're you're on the carnivore diet so
how did that start and when did that
start and why did that start
i've been a carnivore about uh four and
a half years now
four years and four months beating me
yeah how long have you been um
december 2017 i was doing meat and salad
before that for a long time but
december 2017. it's amazing the moment
you realize you don't have to do the
salad and then you try it and it's oh
wow life is so much better
yeah it's a pretty weird so what what
like how did you find out about it and
um well i started down the rabbit hole
of reducing carbs and feeling
better about life in i think 2008 or so
2008 was when i was like
that was early yeah well i was uh
i was fat early basically i was pretty
overweight at that time
and i mean i was about 20 30 pounds
heavier than now
and um i decided that you know i need to
do something about it
and uh just
heard and read about carbohydrate
reduction so i started off with just you
know reducing the soda
and reducing the bread that i ate not
even cutting it out just reducing it
immediately felt so much better wow um
so then
you know just kept on uh experimenting
more and more with that and i
i'm not much of a researcher on
issues of diet i've usually this used to
be laziness but now i've come to embrace
it and
accept it as actually quite smart and
i'm quite happy that i had this laziness
um which is that instead of going and
spending hours
on pubmed and reading different papers
about
different things i just tried them for a
couple of weeks and see what happens
that's actually more scientific people
don't realize that but it's actually
more scientific than reading
biased papers yeah i think i've seen you
tweet that yeah actually
um and i i remember i used to think the
same way which is that you know
look it's it's not like somebody's
asking you to go and try some untested
chemical that could end up hurting you
you know you're
still going to be eating um food that
you've eaten before but you're cutting
out foods that you
um that you can cut out and you know
you'll see what happens if you start
feeling bad you can always go back to it
so i just started uh reducing more and
more
and then the more i'd reduce it the more
i'd read about it and then i'd want to
reduce it more
and so it was um basically uh
from 2008 until 2015 i was just
continuously
cutting down more and more and figuring
out more reasons to cut down on more
plants and reduce my consumption of them
until it was in
late 2015 when i came across um
zero carbs in that blog by
esme lafleur and i remember it was just
shocking when when i first saw it i mean
i'd already at that point i was already
very low carb keto probably um
and yeah i'd gone through the period of
trying on keto and doing the keto strips
and i uh
chugged the mcp oil on the dough yeah
um but at this point you know i just saw
that
oh wait just eat me just drink water
yeah it makes sense i mean
everything i've been doing for the last
seven years was just cut down on
carbs and um eat more meat in one way or
the other let's try to take it to the
extreme
and my brother and i tried it for a
month and that was incidentally
another um when michael goldstein as
well
you know on twitter as well bitsteam
that was exactly when he started
trying uh coincidentally he ran across a
similar website
and started trying it out as well so
we've had this journey together
since then with a bitcoin carnivory from
them
and so i tried it for a month and just
haven't looked back
um i mean i'm not a hundred percent
strict about it i'll still
cheat every now and then um
particularly in social occasions back
you know before lockdown when we had
society when i'd meet with people i used
to
i used to like try and always not be the
kind of person who wants to make
my diet the topic of conversation and so
oh yeah
whatever people will serve i'll just go
ahead and eat it um
generally i just eat a lot at home and
so
um i'm i'm never hungry if i'm out so i
don't have to eat so whatever it is that
they're eating i'll just
have whatever everyone's eating and i'll
eat as much as i can and i just won't
make a fuss out of it
um i think that just makes a lot easier
and the good thing about you know
eating well all the time is that you can
handle the occasional
uh you know uh horrible salad or
whatever
oh so you can get away with cheating a
little bit and you don't get
super negative health side effects or
anything not super negative but i feel
lethargic i feel a little slower lower
energy a little less focus
my workout intensity drops a little bit
i can definitely feel it and this is why
it's just
uh it's it's it's really hard for me to
ever go back to eating
like it's not like i'm doing a diet
right now i
i'd have to do a diet to go back to
eating regular food because every bite
i see the negative consequences on me
and i just see myself getting older and
frailer and less sharp and i just don't
want that
yeah fair wow okay that's interesting so
why do you think
is it just you and bitstein who are the
bitcoin guys who are into the carnivore
diet or is it actually bigger than that
because i definitely read about it again
probably on buzzfeed i'm not sure
no it is bigger than that i think the uh
i mean
uh clearly the fact that uh um
you know my book got a little popular
and uh
among bitcoiners and my twitter i'm
constantly posting on steak
and bitstein as well he's produced great
uh
a great website and he's constantly um
sure obviously
it has helped a lot of people have heard
about it but i think there's a deeper
underlying cause there for the linkage
between them
and and we can name several individuals
other
key individuals like for instance zuko
um
who's the ex-husband of
amber o'hearn the two of them are into
cryptography and they've
also been carnivores so they they're
also pretty influential you know i know
that
yeah yeah yeah amber um yeah amber has
also
uh written a lot of great stuff so
there's quite a few individuals
which you could attribute this to but i
think
um you know i there are a lot of other
uh quirky interests among bitcoiners and
among congress that
don't have this level of overlap and i
think that suggests something much
deeper
and for me the way that i see it is
um you know all throughout human history
people have used
the hardest thing available as money and
people have eaten the biggest
mammal they can hunt as rooted this is
just what all
humans and all societies have always
done and so
um currently the vast majority of people
are
conditioned through many years of
agricultural industrial uh education
that junk is the best thing you can do
to your body that
yeah you know your digestive system
exists to give you sugar highs basically
and the more colorful and
process the food is the bigger the sugar
high and so this is really why your
digestive system exists
so you know if you and and similarly
the point of money is for government to
be able to control it so that they could
then control
life and fix the world with their
control of money
yeah so you'll notice um i think the the
better way
the the way that i like to phrase the
question
it's not curious why bitcoin is a
carnivorous i think what's
rather more curious is why do all of
these uh people who use these bad forms
of money also eat chickpea food
i think that's that's the question that
we need to ask you
like why is it that paul krugman tweets
about soy burgers
and tweets about making soy pasta
bolognese
yeah it's it's astonishing and you know
if you read the financial
press if you need if you read the new
york times
um their views on money and on economics
are similar to that oh yeah and
it's the same exact thing so the same
kind of mentality that is predisposed
toward believing the new york times
towards overcoming its own reason and
make natural instinct towards eating
what is what what is clearly the food
that makes all humans from all
civilizations from all cultures all over
the world thrive
if you're able to somehow throttle that
and
go and eat industrial junk because the
new york times tells you this is better
for the environment
you know you eat the processed soy or
whatever and you're able to
eat that then you'll also believe what
the new york times tells you about money
and that bitcoin is bad
because you know whatever reasons they
have we need government control of money
and similarly if you happen to not fall
for
those things then you'll find it easy to
fall for
uh the other and so this is why i think
you know
if if you've got it to the point where
you actually tried the carnivore diet
you've gone through a process where
you've been
mocked and sneered at and laughed at and
abused by
everybody from your own family to random
strangers on the internet because you
don't share their
own addictions to junk they're uh
brainwashed
to believe in and so you know it's not
completely outlandish for you when
you're presented with something like
bitcoin where everybody's
walking it's not a time for you to take
a second look
the same thing goes for bitcoins if you
got it to the point where you've
accepted and understood bitcoin and seen
what is going on
and stopped just the um you know the the
the snarky
pre-programmed uh uh reaction that
uh new york times leaders and uh
mainstream
economists have to it if you're able to
overcome that then you can
you're able to handle an idea you know
when you come online and you see a whole
bunch of bitcoins eating only meat
you might laugh about it a little bit
but you'll try it and it's astonishing
how many people have done this like
they have absolutely people who got into
bitcoin with absolutely no background
about food or diet or any interest in
any of that stuff
and you know they like steak because
everybody likes steak nobody doesn't
love steaks
and they hear about those crazy people
trying all steak
and they try it and it's it's if you
have this kind of
ability to think for yourself to
experiment to try out you're going to
fit in with bitcoiners and with
carnivores and
that's why we're having a lot of
bitcoins and a lot of carnivores
yeah i like that i think next time
somebody asks me
why i only eat meat i'm going to say why
don't you that's the real question
but um i like that i like that a lot
uh it's funny i used to do counseling
kind of
just for people who had recently started
the carnivore diet because some of them
have a rough transition and they need to
be told repeatedly that they're not
going to die
and a lot of the people i saw i either
saw really sick people with autoimmune
disorders that were just like this is my
last option
um or like really
productive kind of quirky men
who were like i don't want to spend my
life cooking and cleaning
i just want like they were the people
who wanted soylent like a drink that
they could just
eat and drink and then just be
productive and
the steak a steak diet or a carnivore
diet is that
there's no cooking there's not really
cleaning like you just
eat twice a day or whatever and it's
easy and it's good and it's healthy and
fills you with energy yeah um okay last
question
and i've been asking uh successful
individuals who come on my podcast this
question
just to see if there's an overlap but um
what does your day look like in regards
to
well we know what eating vaguely looks
like but in regards to
waking up and exercise just as a
successful individual
uh i don't know i'm hesitant uh
i'm hesitant too much of an example
because i don't have much
of a set routine and it varies a lot
and you know i don't consider myself an
authority on exercise
but uh you ask so you know
i'll say that i want it even if even if
it doesn't sound great to you
i mean generally what i do is i try and
wake up
as early as possible and generally i
just wake up i never set the alarm but i
wake up early
um it's been uh this has been the case
for quite a few years now but i just
wake up
sometime between 4 30
6. wow already something like that um
this is like on the good days when
things are fine and um
you know i'm in my groove and i'm being
productive
so i wake up early and that's when these
days you know i wake up and i'll just
start
working straight away on these days
usually when i'm writing
and i have a lot of writing to do this
is how i do it i wake up and i just
uh um sometimes i'll do some meditation
sometimes i'll just start
the day writing straight away
and then um about
five days a week i try and do some
exercises
um i do bodyweight exercises at home in
the morning
so i'll do push-ups pull-ups uh
dips and handstand push-ups and
um leg raises and squats
um just a few sets here and there in the
morning sometimes i do it
um sometimes i do it pretty extreme i'll
do three sets to failure
and that's pretty exhausting uh if you
do each one of these the three sets of
the failure
i try and do this about five times a
week four times
uh something like that i keep a couple
of days for uh
uh for focusing on work so that i just
stay in that mood all day and i don't
snap out of it
and um i mean generally i like to
i have i think i would probably prefer
if i were doing one
or two meals a day but i generally do
three because i'd like to have
um food with my family yeah and
my daughter uh you know which if she
needs three meals i think so
we have uh food together so i'll have
breakfast and then get back to work
pretty much but you know this is this is
um this isn't like a daily routine it's
quite likely to get
mixed up with all kinds of uh other
things happening
okay um and then what about bedtime do
you have a set bedtime or is that change
too no that's completely all over the
place generally
do do you try and aim for eight hours or
not really i've always
been pretty uh liberal with my sleep
requirements i've
gone through periods where i've stayed
up once for like more than 60 hours
oh my god that sounds horrible yeah grad
school will do that
and i generally like i i i've gone
through many periods where i'd sleep
four or five hours a day
um and i'll generally be fine and catch
up maybe once a week
so right now you know i'll i'll sleep
uh whenever i just feel like it and when
i get tired i go to sleep
more or less sometimes that ends up
depends
so like if i'm tired i'll i'll sleep in
um
if but if not i'll just wake up early
i i i like to not have the alarm and not
to have the uh
to just let let my body dictate the uh
time rather than the
strict deadlines and alarms and
artificial times
okay and last question uh how many hours
a day or per week do you think you spend
working
well it's tough my wife and i argue
about that
a lot she thinks it's much larger than
it should be
um i don't know it's it's really hard to
say because um
well in in my case you know the line
between work
and is kind of blurry because a lot of
my research
is uh you know a lot of my time on
twitter is just
[ __ ] posting on twitter but some of it
is also you know um
i'm doing have valuable useful stuff for
my work
um that's been quite valuable so
it's it's hard to say it's it's really
difficult to say and it's um
how much does your wife think you work
um i'm gonna guess i'd say
probably eight ten hours a day yeah
but a lot of that is as i said you know
like a lot of it
it's not high focused productive work i
do i do a couple of hours of my focus
productive work in the morning
uh most days that's what i try and aim
for
um this is when i can get like the
majority of the writing
through and then um
yeah it's really hard it's really hard
to say but uh
it's probably too much
yeah it's it's hard when you're enjoying
your work like what are you gonna do for
fun watch tv or
research exactly i can't watch tv i fall
asleep every time i
have a tv turned on in front of me yeah
yeah i don't watch tv either i've been
showing my husband
very select simpsons episodes but that's
about it
okay well thank you very much for coming
on i think that was really informative
and i'm gonna go to the websites you
mentioned and read more
like i said i've just been kind of
dabbling in it but
i think there's something to it at least
learning how to do it so
thank you again and i'll link um all of
your links
below that you sent but maybe just tell
people where they can find you again
uh my website is safeiddean.com
s-a-i-f-e-d-e-a-n
dot com and my twitter is at safe and
dean
um i'm day-to-day uh posting
on all kinds of different things on
twitter but my website contains my
courses
my online courses on economics of the
austrian school and
bitcoin economics and it contains um
more on my forthcoming books
and some of my new research as well so
check that out
okay thanks cheers
[Music]
you